what's your typical writing day
usually i i tend to get up um
anywhere between you know maybe
quarter to six 6 30 um you know again i
i try not to wake my wife um
and uh you know i i get that cup of
coffee
to get my fix my caffeine fix and then
um i'm usually uh
riding in our we have a guest small
guest house i'm usually in the back
there
for me i like i enjoy reading the
newspaper
in the morning for about 30 minutes just
to get my brain sort of drinking coffee
getting my brain going just
i'm an avid reader i always have been
and i feel like reading really starts
you know
um stimulating the mind along with the
caffeine
um but it gets me going so um
yeah i usually so again i try to be
working by about 7 30 or 8 o'clock
and again until
you know i'll work to the late morning
take a break just to get my
head right and then come back and you
know probably the early afternoon and
you know i can go till late afternoon
sometimes
um so that's usually my that's usually
my routine as you said be you know asked
before is that it's there's definitely
there's a rhythm to the rhythm uh
i feel es especially when i'm when i'm
writing and creating
and when you say you're reading the
paper is this an actual newspaper
yes i i know i have um i have friends
and my wife still joke me i i do have
some traditions that i have now parted
ways with and yes it's a
it's a it is a actual paper
i try to i really try to avoid the
screen as much as i can
um because i'm on it all day um so yeah
when i can
usually get you know you know anything
in print
uh it makes just to start my day you
know to get again
get those juices flowing get my brain
working
um i find that writing really or reading
excuse me really
helps the writing for sure and again
doing it
not on a screen are you reading the
first pages
of this yeah it's usually i may i'm a
long time
uh wall street journal fan and i i
happen to read you know
pretty much you know everything
throughout um
[Music]
i you know i'm a fan of their reportage
i think it's pretty much down the middle
i know
not to get into you know we're a very
divided country right now but i
i happen to really
appreciate the fact that they're fairly
down the middle and not too biased
one way or the other um and for me
that's
you know that's important so yeah i mean
knowing what's going on in the world
and in our country uh again um
[Music]
as has really really helps me
and i think helps my writing because you
know you never know where that next idea
is coming from i think a lot of my ideas
over the years have come from you know
magazines or
or articles in the paper uh not
necessarily a wall street journal i read
all kinds of
i used to read news magazines
[Music]
i wrote a script about a militia group
that was
[Music]
derived from a i believe it was a
newsweek article
you know in my a chiropractor at the
time her office
she had this newsweek article on the
rise of militias uh probably this was
around
2010 or so so i wrote another
i wrote another script about a um a
pirate hunter in the
southeast asia which was based on a um
smithsonian article so i always find and
i've i've had
um i had another idea for a script that
was based on a story
recently in the wall street journal so
that's where i derive a lot of my
my ideas from um when i'm writing uh
when i'm
from my film ideas anyway and and then
of course you know take back was hearing
something in the sermon but
you know it was um
uh it was a i guess it i it's a news
related
type story um so i always found that
finding stories in the news you know um
you know again it it i've i've known
people that have just been able to
conjure up
great stories in their mind um and i've
done that a couple times but i feel like
for me just reading about someone and
again this is not
you know you know stealing the article
or anything it's just
coming up like oh that's an interesting
topic and then you know sort of making
it my own it wasn't
never necessarily articles about a
particular person it was about
a particular subject and and you know
that definitely helped um definitely
helped me
you know develop my own stories and give
me that sort of that germ of the idea to
then
take it in the direction i wanted to and
make it my own
who do you model your screenwriting
after
um i don't model it after anyone per se
i i've been i definitely have some
people of influence who i think are
phenomenal writers and obviously their
track record speaks for themselves
themselves but
i've always been
you know obviously william goldman who
you know he's the godfather
of screenwriting um tony gilroy
brian helgeland um david capp
those guys you know when you read
one of their scripts i mean they're just
on a whole other level
and um you know i was i was always
especially
um you know i would say
tony gilroy especially because i feel
like he writes
uh some just brilliant action and
um yeah those those uh those
screenwriters i think for me
were you know set he definitely left a
an impression
and you know how to write just an
entertaining script because
i think sometimes you know the way i try
to write is that i want people to keep
turning pages i know this might be
you know the process for many writers or
what they set out to do but
i really do think it's important is
after all you know you want your
you want your audience to keep going
and i've always believed in just being
as sparse
and concise as possible in my
descriptions and
you know letting the dialogue move the
story along
and not getting so so wrapped up
in you know smart ass dialogue but just
letting the characters again
take the story in the direction and
drive drive the story especially if
you're writing action or
or adventure or thriller type you know
genre films
do you ever subscribe to the idea i know
some people said don't don't delve
too much into one artist's work because
then you might end up emulating them
too much and you wouldn't even realize
it or or no
there is definitely some truth to that
you know um
reading reading a whole a whole array of
of scripts and writers definitely helps
inform you better i i feel like for some
of the scripts that i wrote
i always you know again um
you know if i'm if i'm if somebody's to
write an action
script and they want somebody to just
sort of to again to be a a guy to
somebody a reference for them i would i
would always say look at a gilroy a
helga land or a david kept script
because again i feel like they're
you know i should say that for me
pacing's really important
i want to keep the story moving along at
a fluid pace and i feel like
those guys like um another steve's alien
steve's alien i remember said something
that that
left has has left a lasting impression i
read this years ago where he said
i will cut and cut and cut until if i
cut one
again i'm paraphrasing here i cut one
word
the whole scene falls apart so just
being able to
really make your scenes as lean as
possible
and in your writing and and to keep it
paced and
to keep it moving forward and keep the
story moving forward the character
moving forward
um and i and i do think yes i i
it's good i mean you know read read all
tony gilroy scripts but
obviously i would suggest reading a
whole lot of other scripts and and
getting a sense of that
and again just just try to
stay true to your voice because it is
easy if you read one particular author
or one particular screenwriter
you definitely could fall in the trap of
you know subconsciously
you're writing like them and i think
again they're good reference points but
you just have to again
find your own voice and find your own
rhythm and
pattern um and uh you know stay true to
that
do you remember the first script that
you read it was probably in the late 90s
and i want to say it may have been
chinatown
it may have been chinatown it's been a
while so
yeah it may have been chinatown or even
um saving private ryan
which was a amazing script uh
and chinatown was obviously
robert town just one of the masters as
well um
but i think it may have very well been
chinatown where did you get it in 1998
it would have been
it would have been it would have been uh
through nyu
we they had a fairly they had a library
that you could go and take scripts out
and read and um so that's probably where
i got it
and i haven't having been had been a fan
of
that film growing up and being a k you
know when i was a kid um
you know my mom and dad again were very
liberated they let us get away with
watching
you know what now i think parents you
know maybe over
protect but again the 80s were you know
the 80s were a different time
but um you know we were my mom and dad
you know exposed us to you know many of
the great movies like i i
might i first watched french connection
which is my favorite film
uh of all time bar none um when i was i
think
nine it was uh running on the um
on the local fox affiliate in new york
and you know my dad had loved that movie
and he said it's a great film and we
watched it commercials and all and
it's funny because i think that summer
it may have been the summer of 87 or 86
it was on like probably every other week
it was maybe this is the 80s and they
you know it was a summer film they just
kept running
over time uh over the the course of the
summer or that period of time
um but it was uh yeah i i really loved
it and not long after that you know we
saw the godfather and
and so i think i had probably seen
chinatown and the godfather
both godfather films and in chinatown
are in french connection before i was
10.
so i was exposed to film you know from a
really young age
um and
[Music]
yeah that was so um yeah so
that was and and your your question
about uh chinatown was yeah i
i probably got that script at the at the
nyu library
you